I'm an Oscar nominee so I love saying
that whatever happens I'm gonna always
thinking that Oscar nominee part um I
don't know that you can consider
yourself appear just because you you've
got that nomination they've been doing
it for a lot longer and touched a lot of
lives maybe in about five years time
after I get more browned underneath my
belt but I certainly am glad to be in
the room I'll tell you that over there
it's just a bunch of really normal
people who happen to be named Glenn
Close and George Clooney and Brad Pitt
and sometimes you just find yourself
kind of ogling them and you I still do
but they they've they've been very
gracious throughout this whole thing but
as far as the being out there promoting
the film it's one that I'm thrilled to
be a part of and I never had to do this
before so I enjoy every aspect of it I
like reading roles that are substantive
in a part of movies that somehow have a
will or could potentially have a social
impact so that's great and then I like
reading substance of roles that are just
fun I mean I I hope that I can be a
symbol of hope for all the other actors
who've been doing it as long as I have
and and it says something about
perseverance and and staying in the game
I am of the mindset that this is my
first time to the party and I'm going to
enjoy every aspect of it so I am this
smile is real